public shaming or as we call it in
England parenting thanks for the
Internet it has never been easier to
pile onto a public shaming in fact it's
now one of America's favorite pastimes
in Wisconsin families photo shoots gone
viral and now it's sparking some outrage
online viral video leads to outrage on
Long Island now the outrage over another
viral video the outrage machine never
seemed to rest as actress Sarah Michelle
Gellar found out some people online are
just looking for an excuse to be angry
wait what did Sarah Michelle Gellar -
I'm already so angry about it actually
don't tell me I just realized I
definitely don't care the point is this
is a golden age of internet shaming
you've probably participated in it if
you've ever been mad at a potential
Oscar host with shitty tweets a company
who made a blackface shirt
a beloved Irish actor who want to commit
embraces murder and an aquarium that
called an otter Thicke a gender-reveal
party that started a wildfire whoever
attacked justice Millette
whoever didn't believe justice Millette
and finally justice Millette we're
basically goldfish except instead of
discovering a new castle in our bowl
every nine seconds we find something new
to be outraged about online and you may
be expecting me to say that all public
shaming is bad but I don't actually
think that when it's well directed a lot
of good can come out of it if someone's
caught doing something racist or a
powerful person is behaving badly it can
increase accountability in fact just
this week it emerged that Tucker Carlson
the answer to the question wanted to
sound thud grew a face I've said some
awful things on a radio show a few years
prior to here tuck still it that meant
he was unfairly caught up in public
shaming the great American outrage
machine is a remarkable thing one day
you're having dinner with your family
imagining everything is fine the next
your phone is exploding with calls from
reporters okay first of all no one
having dinner with Tucker Carlson has
ever imagined that everything was fine
most people's answer to the question if
you could have dinner with anyone living
or dead is Tucker Carlson dead
and if you look into why Tucker was
caught in that outrage machine it's
because he publicly called Iraqis
semi-literate primitive monkeys compared
women to dogs and basically said that
Warren Jeffs who was serving a life
sentence for the sexual assault of his
underage Brides wasn't that bad now
Tucker refused to apologize and all week
long they've been trending hashtags like
boycott Tucker Carlson and fire Tucker
Carlson and Tucker Carlson Fox's Roomba
but that one wasn't technically trending
but I have this weird feeling that it
will be in 20 minutes or so but Tucker
is actually a good example of an
Internet pylon being merited he's a
public figure
he made his comments publicly they are
appalling and he's standing by them but
clearly it's not always that simple
because when misdirected Internet pylons
can completely destroy people's lives so
tonight let's try and talk about the
power of public shaming because often it
is not a famous figure who's on the
receiving end of it on a seemingly daily
basis ordinary people who did not ask
for attention can't get sucked into the
spotlight like this woman did a few
years ago they're calling her the aunt
from hell and the Antichrist an aunt
filed suit against her 12 year old
nephew she claims she broke her wrist
when he jumped into her arms she sued
her young nephew for 127 thousand
dollars that's right 127 thousand
dollars over a hug the aunt's defense
was that when she goes to a cocktail
party now she actually said this was it
she finds it very difficult to hold the
plate when the hors d'oeuvres are passed
because of her wrist that sounds
terrible although I will say this I know
this isn't the point but everyone finds
it very difficult to hold an hors
d'oeuvre plate you have a plate in one
hand a glass of wine in the other how do
you eat do you grab food off the plate
with your teeth like some kind of
trained horse
do you hold the wine in your armpit
while you grab food with the other hand
and then spend the rest of the night
drinking armpit wine
it's an unsolvable puzzle but it is
pretty shitty to force a 12 year old boy
to pay six figures for hugging you too
enthusiastically which is of course what
she didn't actually do that the real
story is much more complicated very
basically her health insurance did not
cover all her massive medical bills so
to cover her costs her best option was
to go through her relatives homeowner's
insurance but to do that she had to name
a person in a lawsuit even though the
kid and his family were completely fine
with it and they would not be required
to pay she actually went on The Today
Show to explain all of this after the
story blew up unfortunately it didn't
seem to undo the damage maybe because
even what she was discussing the actual
facts the Today Show's graphics read
worst aren't ever speaks out which
doesn't really help does it
meanwhile she was being relentlessly
attacked all over the internet meaning
anyone googling her in the future would
likely be inundated by the inaccurate
version of that story which as she will
tell you became a real problem when she
was looking for work it was very
difficult to find another job people
reached out and then canceled interviews
or then said oh we've changed our
direction I've taken had to take certain
measures in order to reestablish myself
and I have a refreshed identity that's a
pretty drastic measure to have to take
so to help her move past this if you do
talk about the show tonight remember to
tag it with the hashtag just a normal
aunt
hashtag aren't from not hell hashtag
Tucker Carlson Fox is grown there was
every reason for her to believe that
refreshing her identity was necessary
because fully two months after she went
on TV to correct the record Fox News was
having this discussion
listen hashtag worst and ever but I will
tell you that she did then come on to
one of the media outlets and say that
she needed she was injured obviously and
wanted to sue the homeowners
association but had to or homeowners
insurance and had to name him as the
party and felt bad
about it by the way she fell because he
was so excited to see her he stopped me
Jen I love you I love you what are you
doing there this is the worst aren't
ever but in all seriousness she legally
did the only thing that she could have
done and feels quite remorse about it
but the important thing here is she's
the worst
aunt ever and now I'm not saying those
television personalities are all
terrible people they just want to fill
time more than they want to say things
that are true but at some point it's
incumbent on everyone to consider both
context and consequences if you're going
to pile on in a shaming and I'm not
saying that anything here is easy for
instance did I just publicly shame that
lawyer in the last clip yeah I probably
did and honestly I'm absolutely fine
with that just as I'm fine with calling
him a human popped collar who's every
facial expression says I only wish
greenbook had won more Oscars look let's
be honest we make fun of people
constantly on this show it's a comedy
show although for what it is worth we do
think probably more carefully than you
might imagine
about who we're making fun of why we're
doing it and how we ask ourselves
questions all the time like should we
use their name how much power do they
have and do they have a soul patch that
last one could be a real deal breaker
and I'm not saying that we're perfect at
all you might disagree with choices that
we've made but we have honestly thought
about it and sometimes the decision does
get difficult just look at another major
scandal that broke this week concerning
fraud in college admissions actresses
Felicity Huffman and Lauri Lachlan among
33 wealthy parents accused of bribing
coaches and administrators to get their
kids into elite universities Lachlan and
her husband Massimo Gianelli allegedly
put up half a million dollars in
exchange for getting their two daughters
recruited to the USC crew team even
though they did not participate in crew
okay that is such a weird story I don't
think anyone guess that the next big
celebrity scandal would be aunts Becky
from Full House allegedly spends half a
million dollars so a guy will pretend
her daughter's a good at boats
and incidentally if that's all true
worst aren't ever the truth is I've got
no problem making fun of the parents
accused of doing that or the guy who ran
that service where it gets more
complicated is with the kids how much is
it fair to make fun of them well I would
argue that one of them Olivia Jade is a
public figure
she has nearly one and a half million
followers on Instagram and has worked
with all these companies she's actively
made money off her brand as a fun
relatable college students releasing
videos like this I don't know how much
of school I'm gonna attend but I do want
the experience of like gamedays partying
I don't really care about school as you
guys all know huh okay so even before
what we learned this week that was a
little tone deaf although not quite as
tone death as this sponsored post that
she made for Amazon in which she's
decorated her dorm room at USC with the
letters oj and if you don't see a
connection between the letters oj and
USC maybe it should cost half a million
dollars to get you in there now I'm
comfortable I'm comfortable making those
jokes am i comfortable with the whole
internet piling on her honestly
that kind of depends on how and for how
long if it's death threats and viral
comments then of course not if it
defines her forever that seems unfair
the window for making fun of her is
probably closing although I will say it
should stay open just long enough for me
to tell you one person went to her
Sephora makeup product page and left a
one-star review reading I thought this
would give me the just came from true
practice spend hours rolling on the leg
bro turns out it was all a sham but gets
back
[Music]
that is the difficult thing here when
joining in a pylon there is a lot to
take into account and when millions of
people all feel the need to weigh in and
do it potentially for years the
punishment can be vastly
disproportionate to the offense and
perhaps the best example of this is
Monica Lewinsky two decades ago this
country put her through hell as she will
be the first to tell you overnight I
went from being a completely private
figure to a publicly humiliated one
worldwide I was patient zero of losing a
personal reputation on a global scale
almost instantaneously Wow that has to
be terrifying although in fairness
almost everything is scary when you add
the phrase on a global scale if I said
Karen's ophthalmologist says she's gonna
need reading glasses on a global scale
you would rightly think what the is
going on with Karen's eyes but look
she's not wrong and if you are hazy on
the Monica Lewinsky story at 22 she and
President Clinton began a relationship
that very long story short ended up with
graphic details being made public
through the report by independent
counsel Kenneth Starr and it is
impossible to overstate just how
globally famous Monica and private
details of her life became the media
obsessed over every angle of her story
from tabloid stories like these to
cartoons where microphones pointed at
her face were replaced with penises -
endless late-night comedy jokes look my
hands are not clean here either I wasn't
in the US at the time but ten years
after the fact I was in a Daily Show
piece marking the tenth anniversary of
the scandal above a graphic reading ten
sucking years which is gross it's gross
and many comedians have since publicly
expressed regret about things they said
although one who hasn't and it was among
the most relentless was Jay Leno see
with Monica as President Clinton calls
her my little humid or 1 million samples
of DNA they said is the largest
collection of DNA in the world not
counting Monica Lewinsky's closets and
humidity man I'll tell you people's
clothes are stickier than Monica
Lewinsky's met it was just like you
can't get away with at least one of
these Lewinsky back on her feet and the
Grammy for Best organ recital went to
Monica Lewinsky later those jokes have
not dated well in any sense of the word
and and they're pretty rough especially
coming from a guy who just this week
complained about late night TV saying
he'd like to see a bit of civility come
back you know like that time that he did
a bit with a fake book about Lewinsky
titled the in the Hat and if that's
what he means by civility may I offer my
new book oh the places you can go
yourself Jay Leno and given all of that
it's frankly a miracle that Lewinsky
seems to have emerged with her sense of
humor in tax because when someone
recently tweeted I don't know who Monica
Lewinsky is she replied I'm the chick
from over 125 rap songs which is both
very funny and also technically true
because he's referenced in all these
songs we actually found a hundred and
ninety-three of them and that is and
this may shock you significantly more
rap songs than have mentioned me and to
be honest that kinda feels like a
personal sleight you know what an easy
name to rhyme John I'll show you be gone
Swan Louie Vuitton beef bourguignon lots
of options there you know what also
pretty tight rhyme wise Oliver I don't
want just a piece of want Oliver hitting
all the spots that got mixed like John
Oliver almost nothing but the point
isn't that I should be in more rap songs
although I absolutely should
Lewinsky went through absolute hell to
get to the point where she could make
that joke about being the woman from the
rap songs and it can be easy to forget
just how ferocious and devastating the
public attention was I don't even know
how to begin to describe what it was but
it was to see my face on TV to to read
my name in the newspaper people have no
idea what when this is done what this is
doing this behind the name Monica
Lewinsky there's a person and there is a
family there's so much pain that has
been caused by all this and it is it was
so destructive was so destructive that's
horrifying and it's impossible to
imagine how bad that was but for a
second just try think of the dumbest
thing you did when you were young not
the dumbest thing you got caught doing
the dumbest thing you did the thing
you've stole or cheated on or
accidentally sexted and again I am sorry
mom now imagine hearing about that every
single day for decades on end that's a
little bit of what it was like to be
Monica Lewinsky and I know everything
about the subject of public shaming is
complicated but Monica Lewinsky might
actually be the perfect person to remind
all of us what the consequences can be
to a misdirected flood of public anger
and the reason I know this is that I sat
down with Monica earlier this week and
this is what happened 21 years ago
Monica Lewinsky was at the center of a
media frenzy in recent years she's
reimbursed as a major voice on online
shaming and anti-bullying initiatives
and she was kind enough to recently sit
down with me in a fancy apartment that
neither of us live in so in the last few
years you've been doing a lot of work
related to bullying and people being
shamed is it a problem that you think
has gotten worse absolutely I mean I
think that with the advent of the
internet and of course social media we
now have situations where it's
exacerbated beyond I think what anybody
could have imagined initially and the
anonymity that comes with that that that
sort of unleashed these whole new
personas for people it's if you've got
if you have a chance to come up with a
second persona you decide to come up
with exactly how much of an can
I be amplify every aspect of my
personality by a hundred would you agree
that somewhere on the spectrum of shame
there can be positive effects - I'm just
thinking of people who's bad behavior
hurts others and who might not change
that behavior without public and say
yeah you know it's it's interesting I
mean obviously I've spent a lot of time
thinking about this and we tend to look
at it as this kind of like a binary
question right should we public shame we
shouldn't wait I do think there's a
spectrum of behavior on which we could
kind of sort of judge as a society is
this where shaming is effective to
change social behavior or is it damaging
you you were on the receiving end of one
of the worst internet fueled public
shaming of all time and hopefully in a
way ever how the did you get
through that yeah I I don't actually
know you know I mean it was a shitstorm
it was an avalanche of pain and
humiliation and obviously a I could not
have gotten through it without my family
and eventually when I was allowed to
talk to my friends my friends - and I
think as a 24 years old it was you know
really hard to hold on to a shred of
dignity or self esteem when you know
just the butt of so many jokes I'm being
misunderstood right as that everything
escalated all the all the reaction -
what's it like to see this kind of
character of yourself that has your face
and name but what would bears less and
less relevance to who you actually are
sorry I mean it was just it was I say
extraordinary not with any positive
connotation and I think it was not only
just the slut-shaming not only you know
having had an intimate relationship with
someone who is now describing me in a
way
it was like no young woman would want to
be described there was just also my
looks I mean night I you know was very
about the touch-ups and the makeup
because I like part of my vanity now
comes from just the wound of having been
made fun of for my wait for you know
people saying I I was unattractive and
it was terrifying not only because I was
watching myself or this version of
myself I running away from me I mean
stolen my identity was stolen only a
different way I would not to see that I
wasn't flawed and you know that I didn't
make terrible mistakes or do stupid
things or say stupid things because of
course they did well you know right so
every 22 year-old is some version of an
idiot you just lost a lot of you not
whichever 22 year old is now I'm not you
so it's so mean it's not it's not like I
was this you know perfect angel right
but I watched this sort of
deconstruction of me and rebuilding of
me it's like a transformer almost many
many victims of public shaming say it
affects their ability to earn a living
did that happen to you Oh 150% I mean I
couldn't I couldn't get a job I and that
actually it was you know it was
interesting because I went to graduate
school in 2005 and graduated in 2006
then I thought oh okay now I will begin
my life I will now put being Monica
Lewinsky behind me and move on to be
so-and-so's employee and when I couldn't
find a job you know either somebody
offered me a job for the wrong reasons
like oh you'll be coming to our events
that's your job and there's media there
you know or people saying to me you know
the opposite of well could you get a
letter of indemnification from the
Clintons like because we rely on
government money and Hillary might be
President so really I mean there was
this wide range of not being able to
support myself
and also have a purpose which was which
is equally important to feel that you
you matter in some way is it is it tough
sometimes just to get through it yes the
people dying every year question
no that's probably a fair response to
basically most of the things here is it
tough though sometimes just to get
through a typical day without having to
deal with this because the ubiquity
of references to you is incredible it's
insane I think you know in an in part a
lotta that happened because of this you
know sexist really thing that happened
which is that the scandal was named
after me became named over me so it
meant then anytime that this has been
referenced every single day every single
day in the past 20 years so it may not
be a direct reference to me but because
the investigation and the scandal has my
name I'm then therefore attached to it
did you ever consider changing your name
there were several reasons they didn't I
mean first of all I don't think that it
really would have even worked like when
I was job hunting people even suggested
you know why don't you put a different
name on your CV when you're I thought so
then I'm gonna walk into an office for
an interview and and the person
screaming like a person looks like
Monica Lewinsky you know and be
wondering and you're starting out a
professional relationship on a lie so
there's not that and then lastly I think
it was also a principal in the sense
that Bill Clinton didn't have to change
his name nobody's ever asked him did he
think he should change his name and so I
think that that was an important that's
an important statement you know I'm not
proud of all of the choices I've made in
my life but I'm I'm proud of the person
I am I'm not ashamed of Who I am
and I think that that is as hard as it
has been to have that last name
sometimes and the pain that I have felt
of what it's meant for that other people
in my family who have that last name I
am glad I didn't change it I definitely
don't have your courage or strength of
character I don't know honestly I really
believe you don't know that oh no I
already have a mental list of fake names
that's I'm going to do Alvin I like oh
it's not a great name but I think I can
count off you can you actually could
really carry off Alvin Thank You Monica
oh you think I could too I don't know
about Alvin Oliver that's that's a lot
that's true that's not great my second
one was Jack's no surname no explanation
just jacks I like that I could get
behind that one so let's talk a bit
about like laughing because you joke
about your experiences how long did it
take you to get to the point where you
could do that I think there are stages
you know or things that have happened a
couple years ago a friend of mine had
she and her friend had a 25th friend
over Surrey party and they had met in
the 90s so this party that they had for
all their friends to celebrate their
friendship started in the 90s meant
everybody had to come dressed in is from
the 90s I was like oh
I just thought okay you know so for the
first time in about 18 years I donned a
black beret and went to my friend's
party if it could you know in part
because I thought it was pun was funny
oh it's definitely funny right is that
not a marker for actually having come a
long way though that you're able to
actively participate in humor connected
to what you went through which again to
reiterate was clearly anything yeah I
like beret things I can laugh at other
item of clothing jokes not as much what
is your experience of the internet now
because because you you're on Twitter
now and you're very funny on thank you
so how did you decide to go on it cuz
like I guess some of the times that I
get really deflated what do you tweet
something funny and then making the
mistake of scrolling down oh yeah it can
become a sewer pretty fast yeah it can I
mean I I get a lot of empowerment out of
blocking people so I wish people would
not say shitty things but they do sure
and literally to me it's like when I
block someone I'm like going oh really
that's literally what it feels like for
me is that I'm basically telling someone
to off
it feels great so I mean I wish they
hadn't said something that would make me
want to block them to begin with but
blocking is unbelievably empowering I
mean actually I I was lucky in some ways
that social media wasn't around I think
that would have made it worse in some
ways and I don't have made it worse I
know I do not maxed out
it could be do you really think it could
ago was I guess maybe you know I I don't
I don't know so I mean it might have
been worse in the sense that there
certainly would have been a lot more
opinions that were out there but where
it may have been better would have been
that I think I would have heard some
support from people so it might have
been a little more balanced so would it
have been really meaningful to you at
the time had social media being around
just to have a stranger tweet something
like I think what you're going through
is complete yeah yeah it would
absolutely because one of the things
that happens with these kinds of
experiences is that you just you start
to disappear you start to feel like you
don't matter and I think that when
somebody sees you you know and just
acknowledges your humanity in the
smallest way it really can make a world
of difference you don't know it could
help save someone's life and they think
that's important what would your advice
be to someone who is either in the eye
right now of the storm of public shaming
or a kid who's being humiliated at
school online is there anything that
you'd be able to tell them from your
personal experience that nobody else
could the first thing I'd probably say
is that you can get through it you can
move past it I know it feels like in
this one moment that your life will
forever be defined by this but it won't
and it may be hard it may take more time
than you ever could have imagined but
you can move past something like this
Monica Lewinsky thank you so much for
talking
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you